then there are luminaries wise elderly
Statesmen that we have like Joe Biden
the elderly man pretending to be
president and he was asked what he
thought about these Supreme Court
decisions with all his incredible wisdom
take a look
I think the court misinterpreted the
Constitution
I get it he's mind muddled or whatever
he knows they didn't misinterpret the
Constitution where in the constitution
does it say if you take out loans that
the government should be able to wipe
away those loans where in the
constitution does it say that schools
should be allowed to discriminate
against people that would be against the
Constitution because we have individual
rights you get it with the with the
Colorado website designer where it is in
the Constitution to say you should force
people to use their artistic skills in a
way that you wish that they could it's
everything they say is nonsense that's
why it's never detailed it's never
nuanced right it's these broad sweeping
statements show me I'm trying here to
give you like the specifics well what is
in the Constitution individual rights
are in the Constitution right free
speech is in the Constitution for
example uh the right to bear arms the
right to peaceably assemble Etc there
are things that are specifically in
there but they take things that are not
in there abortion and then if you kick
it back to the states which is in the
Constitution if it's not in the
Constitution you let you leave it up to
the states not up to the federal
government these are all see the problem
also is that they don't care about any
of these things like we can all talk
about how the thing is supposed to work
we can talk about what's in the
Constitution we can talk about what's in
the Bill of Rights and all of those
things but the more that it goes against
their agenda to them that's more fuel to
the fire to burn down these documents
and all of our institutions in the first
place uh but some other things have
happened over the last couple days that
are also kneecapping Joe Biden's
authoritarian to use aoc's word uh
agenda uh here is a federal judge now
has issued an order that the executive
agencies the CIA FBI et cetera et cetera
they are no longer allowed to collude
with big tech companies to censor you I
thought that was sort of baked into the
whole freaking thing already but we know
over the last couple years it's not
here's a little more on that federal
judge says the Biden Administration Bank
violated the First Amendment during the
pandemic by censoring social media posts
Justice correspondent David spun reports
live from the D.C Newsroom David what
can you tell us hi Jillian this is a
temporary injunction not a final ruling
however this temporary injunction could
have major implications on Free Speech
it came down today on a Federal holiday
from a federal judge in Louisiana Judge
Terry Dottie blocked officials and
agencies in the Biden Administration
from communicating with social media
companies think Facebook Google Twitter
about the topic of protected speech
okay so before we get to what they've
done in the past what this judge just
did with this temporary injection is
fantastic right we know that the CIA the
FBI the intelligence agencies that they
were working with tech companies we know
that I've showed you a billion clips of
all of that right Jen sake we flag posts
for Facebook at the height of kovid we
now know through the Twitter files that
there were eight government agents
literally working at Twitter some of
them may still work there now so God
only knows how many of them work at
Facebook and YouTube and everything else
once a government agent is doing
something with a big Tech organization
to censor you or to imply censorship
there were also emails leaked where
government agents were basically saying
we know this from Mark Zuckerberg on Joe
Biden we've uh on Joe Biden on Joe Rogan
we've shown you that clip uh where
Zuckerberg said you know a little bit
before the hunter Biden story broke we
got word from the government that
something was coming and we should just
cool it so we did what we could right so
they have absolutely infringed on My
First Amendment right to free speech and
your First Amendment right to free
speech